Yes, thank god.
I don't think anything got ruined.
Like,
I do have baby memories that have water marks on them now and stuff,
but since I got to it and I was able to get everything dry,
nothing was like ruined. It just.
It has new memories attached to it.
Um, I think my boyfriend was able to like,
dry out all of his things.
And the other thing that came of it was, um,
I woke up the next morning like,
so. Like,
my nerves were fucking shot.
I was like, like buzzing
even at like 6 o'clock in the morning.
And I was like, so convinced,
like in previous relationships,
I somehow would be in trouble for that.
Like, I would.
It would be my fault. I'm the one who needed to move to this place.
I'm the one who wanted it
or I'm the one who didn't think clearly.
Somehow, some way,
it would have been 1,000% my fault
and I would have been in trouble
and I would have been like,
in the dog house for weeks, months.
It would have been something I never hear the end up,
you know what I mean? Like,
oh my god. I was like,
so like, oh my god.
And he woke up giving me hugs and kisses and,
you know, everything's okay.
And then, um,
even when the water thing was happening
and the carpet people were coming
and he was trying to put my kids beds Together.
And I had to run to the grocery store,
and then I was, like,
stressed about dinner. He ordered $80 worth of pizza.
I ordered, like,
15 times more pizza than we needed,
so I had enough for, like,
dinner and lunch the next day.
And then, like I said,
he woke up in the morning giving me, like,
hugs and kisses and reassuring me that, like,
he's not mad at me. It's not my fucking fault.
I didn't, like,
burst the pipe myself or anything.
So it turned out to be a really,
like, a little bit of a good experience
because nothing was ruined.
The carpet got dry. Like,
my property management company was.
Own it. The guy,
the maintenance guy came yesterday to fix the water line and to make.
And to hook up our cooler.
So, like,
it's even better than it was.
So, um. Yeah.
Yeah, nothing got ruined. If.
And it's, like,
literally brought us closer together and made me just, like,
even more confident of, like. Okay, yeah.
He is the man I thought he was.
I'm happy that he is my, like,
partner in this, not just like a.
I don't know, a burden or,
you know. So thanks for all the love and checking in.